Louisenlund: einst Sitz eines Herzogs,
heute ein privates Internat.
Es ist alles neuer.
Also die Kittel sind noch sauber,
die Brillen sind nicht zerkratzt
und man kann mit den ganzen Sachen
arbeiten.
Die Bertold-Brecht-Oberschule:
gebaut vor fast 30 Jahren – staatlich.
Man integriert zu wenig die
modernen Sachen.
Man benutzt immer noch Schulbücher.
Man schreibt immer noch mit Kreide.
Wer nach Louisenlund will,
braucht reiche Eltern –
oder ein Stipendium wie Björk Lucas.
Seit der neunten Klasse geht sie
auf das Gymnasium.
Sie und ihre Mitschüler sind in der
Schwerpunktklasse Chemie, Bio und Physik.
Vor zwei Jahren wechselte sie von einem
öffentlichen Gymnasium hierher.
Also, wenn ich die Ausstattung
von meiner alten Schule mit hier vergleiche:
Also, hier funktioniert alles schon
deutlich besser und es ist einfach sauberer,
es ist neuer, man kann viel besser
mit den Sachen arbeiten.
Also, ich denke mal,
es ist klar, dass es da Dinge gibt
die einem nicht so gefallen an der Schule,
aber das ist jetzt glaub ich nicht nur
an der BBO so.
Es sind viele Schulen in Berlin.
Tom Colm geht auf die
Bertold-Brecht-Oberschule.
Hier schrumpfen die jährlichen 35.000 Euro
aus Louisenlund
auf durchschnittlich 8.900 Euro
pro Kind zusammen.
Nach der 10. Klasse will er sein Abi machen
und Mediengestalter werden.
Bei der Einschulung entschieden sich
seine Eltern bewusst
gegen die Privatschule für ihre Kinder.
Ja, wir haben das natürlich diskutiert:
Sowohl in der Familie,
wie auch wir als Eltern alleine.
Es war ein langer Prozess,
aber aufgrund der Erfahrung,
die ich an einer Privatschule gemacht hab,
haben wir uns dagegen entschieden.
Ein wichtiger Aspekt war auch
die Erkenntnis,
dass die Probleme,
die auf unsere Kinder zukommen,
in den allermeisten Fällen ja doch
gesellschaftliche Probleme sein werden.
Und wenn man die Gesellschaft nicht kennt,
tut man sich schwer,
ihre Probleme zu lösen.
In Louisenlund in der Physikstunde
sitzt Björk
mit nur drei anderen Schülern
im Unterricht.
Die 35.000 Euro ihres Stipendiums fließen
komplett in moderne Ausstattung,
den Unterricht und Unterbringung
der Schüler.
Einen Gewinn darf die Schule als Stiftung
nicht machen –
für Björk ein deutlich besseres Konzept.
Der größte Unterschied zu
meiner alten Schule ist, glaube ich,
dass die Lehrer viel mehr Zeit
für jeden einzelnen Schüler haben.
Jeder Lehrer kennt einen viel besser.
Jeder Lehrer kennt seine …
die Stärken und Schwächen der Schüler.
Toms Klassenlehrerin jongliert dagegen
20, 25 Kinder pro Klasse.
Lehrerinnen wie sie werden dringend
gebraucht:
Fast 40.000 Pädagogen fehlen
in Deutschland.
Ihre Schule hat zwar technisches Equipment
wie Computer,
aber zu wenige für 1500 Schüler.
Manchmal ist es so – dadurch,
dass die Schule so groß ist –,
dass man dann nicht so schnell
an die verschiedenen Sachen rankommt
und dann es doch wieder vertagen muss
auf andere Stunden,
weil man in dem Moment nicht
die Möglichkeit hat,
das im Unterricht umzusetzen.
Neben Lehrermangel plagen viele
öffentliche Schulen
auch baufällige Gebäude und
Sanierungsstaus.
Gearbeitet wird deshalb oft
im laufenden Betrieb.
Anders die privaten Schulen:
Die finanzieren sich durch Spenden
und Schulgeld,
sind weitestgehend unabhängig
von der Politik –
zwei parallele Welten, von denen sich Tom
nicht entmutigen lassen will.
Ich glaube schon, dass viele Schüler
so die gleichen Chancen haben,
erfolgreich zu werden – je nachdem,
was sie halt machen wollen.
Ich glaube, das kommt ganz
auf den Schüler selbst an.
Optimismus eines 15-Jährigen.
Fakt ist aber:
Deutschland investiert nur 4,1 Prozent
des Bruttoinlandsprodukts in Bildung.
Und das liegt noch unter dem
europäischen Durchschnitt.